I've got some really interesting stories
on today's bonus show of this first one
which was actually selected and sent to
me by Rachel there's been this issue
with Airbnb which is the housing rental
site which people sometimes use for
longer term rentals short term rentals
vacations alternative to hotels options
in areas that have very few hotels it's
really a major major uh website at this
point that spans the entire globe
actually they've been criticized because
it's very easy or at least it was very
easy on Airbnb to discriminate on the
basis of gender on the basis of race on
the basis of age etcetera etcetera the
idea of Airbnb is it sort of based on a
reputation economy where uh you would be
able to as that as a a renter you can
review the landlord and as a landlord
you can review the renter and then
ideally the good landlords have a higher
reputation rating and the good renters
have a higher reputation rating and this
is the basis on which people will be
accepted or denied for rental periods
unfortunately there are a number of
cases which suggests to us that this is
not the case individuals of individual
cases of people not being rented to
seemingly because of their race now how
would how would a landlord know their
race because of user photographs that
are required on Airbnb so Airbnb now has
said we are going to take action to try
to combat discrimination number one the
rental hosts the landlords for for lack
of a better term need to agree to a
community commitment that will start on
November first which will include a
non-discrimination policy that's good
although it's it pretty hard to enforce
something like that because the
landlord's can say oh yeah yeah I'm
adhering to that policy but that doesn't
mean I have to just accept any renter
the other change is that Airbnb is going
to reduce the prominence of user
photographs which obviously if you look
at a user photograph generally speaking
you can tell the both the race and the
under of the individual that is
attempting to rent here although again
they're going to reduce the prominence
of user photographs one of the big
things on Airbnb is they want to make
sure that they know who it is that is
renting and one of the ways they enforce
that is by having you upload a
photograph profile picture sort of like
what you would see on facebook so you
can reduce the prominence but unless you
hide it from the landlord or host all
together I don't exactly know how you
can ensure that there is not going to be
discrimination so uh this is a bit a
pretty big issue that is creating a sort
of black cloud over air B&B in many
areas it's now in 34 thousand cities
it's in a hundred ninety-one countries
it is absolutely huge and when you think
about the types of people the background
and I'm not talking about just race and
gender but also economic backgrounds and
and in so many other areas that could be
renting in different countries etcetera
this is absolutely an issue now let me
tell you another layer of this that is
very interesting I spoke to a friend of
mine over the weekend who is a real
estate and landlord tenant attorney here
in Massachusetts and the laws may be
different from from state to state in
Massachusetts it is not illegal if you
are advertising a room for rent in your
house it is not illegal to reject
individuals based on sexual orientation
for example this would be different than
if you are renting an apartment and it
is truly a uh uh an apartment rental
that would be more governed by law but
if you were renting a room in your house
you may not be able to and this is the
part that was less clear because he the
conversation was interrupted you may not
be able to advertise and I think I'm
pretty sure you can't advertise looking
for a heterosexual roommate for a room
in my house that I am pretty sure is not
allowed but there would be nothing
requiring you to hide if you say you
know really I I want someone who is
heterosexual sharing this room in my
house my understanding based on what my
real estate attorney friend told me is
that is
actually not against the law so this is
really an Airbnb policy that they are
proactively attempting to put in place
non-discrimination not something that is
required by law at least in
Massachusetts when it comes to
individual room rentals something
interesting to keep in mind on my
upcoming trip I'm actually going to be
using air B&B for the first time and I
am NOT renting a room in some guys house
or something like that I'm actually
going through there are some sort of
management companies that will manage a
bunch of air B&B entire apartments and I
very carefully selected one that has
very very high positive views we will
see my sense is that it will be a
positive experience